find critical points and hands graph
okay so what is this thing going to look
like well let's think about stationary
points first and then we'll move on to
Point C inflection okay in order to find
my stationary points and determine their
nature I'm going to need the first to
review right which is some dummy 3x
squared okay yeah that's what you meant
to say right now what I'm gonna do here
is I'm gonna factorize right right away
okay I actually probably should have
done it earlier on as well because this
will tell me the roots and this is for
me the stationary points okay so here I
can take out a factor of x squared so
that leaves me with X minus 3 so you can
read the ritz off that right what are
the two roots 0 3 right
okay now here when I factorize I can
take out a 3x right so that'll leave me
with X minus that check out okay so
again off here you can read off the
stationary points right yeah we're still
gonna draw this thing I am gonna draw it
okay so yeah that's why if all the
question was to find critical points I
wouldn't need that okay where are the
stationary points there's one at zero
which you want to expected because
actually it's a double root and then
there's another one at two yep okay so
at the moment I'm finding the critical
points for the sake of graphing right so
if the question was you know if the
question had nothing to do with the
graph and was find the station place to
determine their nature okay you have to
be a little more rigorous about how you
set things out but here because I'm just
doing this for the sake of this this is
enough really okay
when someone's marking they're paying
attention to this yes yes so if it was
clear on there you know and you actually
have put in the locations of the station
for it and that kind of thing that would
be enough however I mean like most
graphs even this form which is very
simple to know the location of the
station points you would have had to add
some working right and I sort of I mean
I know some people are really keen on
having some awful messy scratchy piece
of paper and they do all this stuff on
there and then this is what they present
but being that you have to go through
this logically anyway to work out what
this looks like at least make it look
half decent I mean this is not beautiful
but I could present this and I wouldn't
be embarrassed about
right so I think it's better to actually
produce this have it be legible and have
it present a longish solution rather
than kind of riding on the fact that you
ought to be okay without any working why
not include the working
we'll also help you when you're coming
back and you're open you graph and
you've got a little rid of all of your
rough working paper you're like is this
right I don't know because I don't know
what my workin was right
so working is really for you that makes
sense I cants keep going second
derivative I'm gonna go from this swamp
rather than the factorized form so
that's just going to turn the 6x6 okay
so if I factorize again again I can see
I'm not gonna say points of inflection
so don't really know what I want to say
possible points of inflection okay so
far so good
now let's think about what this thing
will look like okay because without
doing more work we can already get a
pretty good idea of what this is doing
okay roots at 0 and 3 okay so there's
the origin and you want to be careful
for your scale here now because now that
we know much more about graphs they're
going to be more stringent on having
everything in the right place okay so 0
1 2 3 probably useful that have this
scale good anyway because all of these
are going to be critical points okay so
I've got 1 2 & 3
okay now we were expecting a double root
at 0 okay double root of 0 and then just
one root at 3 this is cubic okay and the
leading coefficient is just 1 and
positive okay so you know how cubics can
either look like this or they can look
like this okay they can be overall
increasing or they can overall the
overall decrease which one is this is
overall increasing right that's what
that positive coefficient tells us okay
so if I had to guess I'd be expecting
I'll put in another color I'd be
expecting this kind of shape right
coming up and then okay so that's what
I'm expecting however now that I know
all these kinds of things I can be more
specific about these kinds of details so
for instance this stationary point okay
here's one of the origin no problems but
I'm expecting one at
- as well so - no more precisely where
that ought to go i want to sub that back
into my equation and find out its
coordinates so i'm gonna get rid of this
approximate line
well my value you get when you pop in x
equals two so we've got a value find a
spot
okay good set it to -4 so i'm gonna pop
that down yeah okay and this is a well
remember from our rough sketch before
this is a minimum right okay so i'm
going to go through there and because
it's a on a stationary point I'm gonna
put a horizontal line there so that when
I complete my graph it's gonna this
curve which is gonna look good at is it
- now I've got a possible point of
inflection at x equals 1 okay now
without actually having tested okay
because I know what this roughly looks
like I actually know it will be a point
of inflection okay so when I put in x
equals 1 you get 1 minus 3 which is
minus 2 okay should be careful since I
said this was minus 4 I'm gonna have to
watch my scale right so that's four
units apparently so if I come across
here that's gonna have to be halfway
where it changes concavity okay all
right
do you think that's enough to put it
together I've also got my stationary
point there which is halfway makes the
point inflection halfway between your
stationary points all right ready go
okay I'm gonna do the in-between part
first make sure that I'm concave down
for this part and concave up for this
part so I look alright then you got your
point of inflection there okay on the
left hand side that's easy because it
just drops off and it doesn't have to
hit anything so I'm just gonna off it
goes okay
and there's my M my max turning point
there at the origin
and I just have to finish this up and
make sure I hit three okay so let's try
that
I almost got there I was so close but
anyway I've already labeled my minimum
I've already got my intercepts later on
that's it I'm finished okay infection I
should also have labeled the corners in
a point inflection okay so one two three
all happy coordinates
any questions on that so I said again oh
yeah thank you okay
label Nancy that's fine yeah finished
okay
happy now read on